making me angry today huh all right do
you want to go to unhelpful advice no i
don't actually
okay let's sit in this atmosphere
[ __ ] foot shavings
are you still angry that i call you
uncle tom
it's also not uncle tom i don't think in
the asian community yeah um
what's it called uncle chan he's uncle
chan
what's the [ __ ] i don't know but i um
no i don't think that i am you know i i
don't i don't follow asians blindly just
because they're asian
you know i think that like there's like
you know um korean zombie i always root
for
you know there's like that um
you're from manchester united park you
know i mean you know i mean do you soon
park
jason park i think yeah yeah um i
i loved him you know i mean i followed
him i love korean movies what about the
guy from tottenham
i love him as well i love him and you
know i love him as well and when he
scores against arsenal
that's the one thing that i don't i
don't i don't get bummed about that i
have to ask you a question about arsenal
what is this thing about a super
european league
we're in europa and we're in the
semifinals no there's something else
they started this like super european
league thing that arsenal is a part of
i think it was just news today it was
weird
well i don't know anyways but so it's
like is it am i
you know you know there's certain asian
standups that i don't like and there's
some asians ones i love
and i identify with you know someone
like david cho i know that you know
we have you know we have certain issues
with them you know i mean
all positive ones um i um
i look at david and when i see david and
that every in the first time i ever saw
him
um i say i i said to myself
it's almost as if we're cut from the
same cloth
you know is there a part of you that
like resents some part of the asian
community because they've told you that
you cannot be this
sort of like who you are no because you
know i had
asians say that to me you know and i go
you know i can only be me
i can only do the kind of comedy that i
do i remember trying to do observational
humor
like sebastian was doing it i was like
maybe i'll try can you try can i can i
hear something what would be
observational i just look around the
room
oh man no we can't be around here but
it's like you know um maybe andres
uh i mean it's like
flying it's like you know
flying crazy it's like you know i was at
the yeah i was in the
emergency ex ezero right and the slight
antenna goes
uh to me you know are you uh
can you in in case of reversing can you
help you know and i
and i go yeah right and then when she
walked away i was like [ __ ] no i don't
know i don't know how to do it i don't
know how to do it man i don't know how
to do it all right
it's like you know um you know when
there's turbulence in the planet
right more planes yeah i mean i you know
i unbuckled myself i was gonna go to the
bathroom and she's like um
this flight attendant's like you know
excuse me sir you got to sit down i go
you're standing
yeah i bet you if we were on the log in
the lake right and we're trying to
balance i'd be able to blouse better
than you
flight attendant don't tell me what to
do you know what i mean i mean if she
could do whatever i can yeah i don't
know how to do it i don't know how to do
observationally
that's
that's funny what else is more
observation you know
i like the plane theme you know you had
so much plane stuff
no it's like that's the com mo like all
hacky road comedy it's either planes
relationships
driving that's the all you know that
everyone can relate to
i just don't know how to do it hey guys
we're gonna take another quick break to
share
some more favorite sponsors of ours
you guys oh my god you know what
tiger belly would not have a business
business without ship station
we use shipstation to to send out our
merchandise and it is the most
efficient the most